all right well there's growing evidence
this morning that artificial sweeteners
could cause health problems
researchers at George Washington
University found the sugar substitute
sucralose might promote high blood sugar
blood pressure and blood sugar unhealthy
cholesterol and abdominal fat the
concerns are greater for people with
diabetes or prediabetes
the ongoing debate over which foods are
most healthy is the subject of dr. mark
hymens latest book food what the heck
should I eat Mark Hyman directs the
Center for functional medicine at the
Cleveland Clinic dr. Hyman great to have
you with us we've been talking about
this book all morning and I guess the
question is it does seem like rules
constantly are changing about what
people should and shouldn't eat is yours
the final Bible well I would be the
final Bible because we're in constant
state of study and learning but the
truth is that we've been confused
because the recommendations from our
government have been based on poor
science and have contradicted a lot of
things that we now know are true for
example that fat is bad that we should
eat me that we should be you know eating
things that were not really supposed to
be eating like whole eggs we're not
supposed to eating but actually egg
whites are good that's actually false
so should we not worry about cholesterol
no in fact the government in the dietary
guidelines in 2015 said that we should
no longer worry about dietary
cholesterol that it's quote no longer a
nutrient of concern meaning that we kind
of got it wrong in the egg whites for a
long time I just think your book was so
confusing no offense because I feel that
it's always changing you have a quiz at
the beginning yes
oatmeal is a healthy breakfast I wrote
true you said that's false yes you
should avoid egg yolks because they
raise your cholesterol and cause heart
attacks I wrote true you said that's
false right red meat is unhealthy and
causes cancer and heart disease I wrote
true and you said that that's full and I
just think that I think I'm confused
about what we're supposed to do you talk
about food as being medicine yes we
should look at it that way yeah and that
it really dictates everything that
happens in our life it's so true food is
not just calories we all believe that we
should eat less and exercise more to
lose weight but we now know that food is
information that its instructions that
literally changes your gene expression
regulates your hormones can affect your
immune system and inflammation in your
body even affects your gut microbiome so
every
bite of food you take his literally like
instructions to control your operating
system of your biology and if you have
quality and you focus on that it's far
more effective than focusing on
quantities it's not about how much wheat
it's about what we we so your messages
stay away from the processed foods if
you look at ingredients in there 25 of
them which might not include the actual
things as it is stay with your badge ah
yes and stay away from sugar right so
those are basically do you eat real food
yeah are gonna be in a part I often
teach at churches and I say it's really
easy just ask yourself did God make this
or did man make this they've got to make
a Twinkie no did not make an avocado yes
it's pretty simple so most of the stuff
we eat our food like substances or
highly processed highly refined with
Drive diabetes obesity heart disease
chronic disease and we really should be
eating food you would you say God made
it keep it God made it eat it you know
if man made it leave it the Twinkie may
be the culmination of God giving I mean
there's 37 ingredients and Twinkies only
one of them is food which is banana
puree at the very bottom of us so it is
there conclusive proof now we talked
about this new research about sugar and
sugar being so detrimental - yeah I mean
there's more than salt overwhelming
evidence that sugar is the biggest
driver of obesity type 2 diabetes cancer
heart disease even dementia they're
calling it type 3 diabetes and it's not
fat it turns out and that's why we got
the whole story wrong we're told these
seven six to 11 servings of bread rice
around pasta a day by the government the
food pyramid it should be called the
food tombstone even say milk does not do
a body good yeah we've been told by the
government in three glasses of milk a
day kids should have to and the truth is
there's very little evidence to support
that and the new guidelines actually
were assessed by the National Academy of
Sciences and said there's very little
evidence for some of these things that
are recommended it's highly industry
influence when people hear you say told
by the government they're gonna think
well how could they have gotten it so
wrong what are you alleging well the
National Academy of Science has just
reviewed the entire process and they
found that the government has actually
in the committee has ignored a lot of
important data for example on saturated
fat on low carb diets on meat and they
basically just assumed that these are
bad and they've also not actually
represented this sign
fully and they haven't completed full
reviews and so and they're all so
industry influenced for example the
Dairy Council fund some of the committee
members in their work so there's a
conflict of interest issue that it was
brought up by the National Academy of
Sciences and we are seeing some change
soda consumption has gone down in the
country yes but it's gone up everywhere
else in the world you also make a point
in saying you're not married to any one
particular diet you're just going though
totally based on the research yeah I
don't I don't have any of the axe to
grind I don't have a particular point of
view I adhere to I just want to know
what the sign says and I've been
practicing nutritional medicine for 30
years and I've actually been studying
nutrition for 40 years and we now know
so much about what to eat and what not
to eat and that's what I tried to
summarize legs got a bad rap dr. Hyman
thank you so much for joining us thanks
and you can find dr. hymens ten day
detox diet on our website cBS This
Morning Calm